Ich kann echt nichts dafür aber in der wissenschaft gibt es halt
Echt fast jeden tag unglaubliche nachrichten die er ist und das ist die meinung eines renommierten
wissenschaftlers für zwei nobelpreise gut es ist ein wirklich wirklich unglaubliche blick die entstehung unseres universums
Gelungen und zwar genau in dem moment in dem unser universum von einer trüben suppe zu dem heutigen
Klaren fast vakuum wurde und die ersten sterne entstanden und dort entdeckte ein forschungsteam etwas absolut verblüffendes eine
außergewöhnliche spur zur dunkle materie alles über die
beschwörer baden brechen der entdeckung jetzt bei pixum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Es waren von 13,6 milliarden jahren 180 millionen jahre nach dem urknall
das größte spektakel unseres universums damals stürzte die wasserstoff ursuppe zu den ersten stern zusammen
sie zündeten und durch ihre
ultraviolette strahlung wird das sie umgebende gas in heißes plasma verwandelt diese plasma blasen verschmelzen und langsam
lichtet sich das universum bis zum schluss nur noch galaxien mit sternen planeten
und schwarzen löchern übrig sind genau an diesem zeitpunkt der entstehung der ersten sterne an diesem zeitpunkt
zu gucken das war bisher unmöglich
So dunkel war die wolke aus wasserstoff und ein wenig helium doch dieses verborgene
Geheimnis wurde jetzt gelüftet die plasma blasen hinterließen ein eigenes strahlungs muster und genau das wurde jetzt gefunden
bei, einer wellenlänge von 21 zentimetern
sorgten sie für eine leicht erhöhte
Absorption der hintergrundstrahlung doch diese leichte strahlungs verringerung zu finden war gar nicht so leicht zu sehr ist unsere erdatmosphäre
durch die menschlich verursachten radiowellen
verunreinigt und auch in unserer galaxie gibt es noch genügend störende strahlungsquellen all das ist im radiowellenbereich
10.000 mal lauter als die gesuchten signale zitat es ist ein wenig so als säße man mitten in einem
Harry, kennt und würde versuchen den flügelschlag eines kolibris zu hören so peter kaczynski von der us national science foundation
doch genau das ist gelungen zum einen hat sich das forschungsteam nach westaustralien
zurückgezogen, wo es möglichst wenig vom menschen verursachter radiowellen gibt und zum anderen haben sie ein vollkommen neues messinstrument entwickelt
Ages das ist ungefähr so groß wie eine tischtennisplatte und imstande diese veränderung der hintergrundstrahlung, zu messen und
Es ist gelungen zitat das profil dieses signals ist konsistent mit den erwartungen für das 21
zentimeter signal der frühesten sterne die frequenz entspricht der zeit von etwa
180 millionen jahre nach dem urknall so das forschungsteam allerdings hat das team etwas gefunden was sie so nicht
erwartet haben denn das was das plasma an strahlung absorbiert hat das ist viel mehr als vorher gesagt wurde und zwar doppelt soviel
zitat diese ergebnisse erfordern einige veränderungen in unseren vorstellungen von der frühen entwicklung unseres universums was könnte
kosmologische modelle beeinflussen und dazu führen dass die theoretiker noch einmal darüber
nachdenken müssen wie dies zu erklären ist sagt colin lonsdale vom haystack
observatoriums m
Und jetzt kommt es könnte dunkler materie für diese delle verantwortlich sein ein grund für die höhere absorption könnte kälteres
wasserstoffgas sein und dafür könnte die dunkle materie
verantwortlich gewesen sein
zitat die einzige kosmische komponente in die kelter sein kann als das früher kosmische gast ist die dunkle materie, so
Rennern balkan von der universität tel aviv das hätte
ernsthafte konsequenzen für die bisherigen modelle der dunkle materie wimps könnten es dann nicht mehr sein sie zeichnen sich ja gerade dadurch
aus dass sie mit normaler materie kaum interagieren stattdessen könnten dann eher aktionen oder
sterile neutrinos für die dunkle materie
verantwortlich sein zitat sollte sich diese hypothese bestätigen dann hätten wir etwas neues und
Grundlegendes über die mysteriöse dunkle materie erfahren das würde uns einen ersten blick auf eine. Physik jenseits des standardmodells
liefern so der projektleiter
Dohmen von der arizona state university es ist also wirklich bahnbrechend was sie entdeckt wurde wenn er als erstes neues zum thema
dunkle materie
zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer
Hierbei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert und ab so gibt es dann auch
Besondere angebote zum beispiel ein ort will gratis abo also unbedingt anmelden
einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der glocke vergessen genau hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
sensationen dunkle materie existiert wahrscheinlich nicht eine ganz andere hypothese zur dunklen materie ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran